[Musique]
et vous vous le hasard surgi en force à
l'échelle macroscopique jeu ça va être
ça que tu me dis parce que l'attraction
d'ordre n'est possible que dans les
systèmes l équilibre oui chérie oui
c'est moi tu vas bien tu as fait bon
voyage
oui je suis pour rien à gérer qu'est-ce
que je suis content de temps en temps tu
sais je t'aime je pense à toi sans h aux
aussi je pense à toi sa me sarr et tu
mama actuellement que 6 qu'est ce que tu
fais en ce moment j'ai en ce moment je
suis en train de regarder les photos de
toi et des petits je suis emporté ne me
dis pas tu emporté une photo de man et
des enfants oui tu es merveilleux tu vas
voir en chair et os je suis tu vois moi
je ne suis pas tout à fait surpris tu
chéris jeune et grand mère dans sa
valise
oui serré chez mes grands mères dans ta
valise c'est le petit cochon ordures
c'est le paradis de grands dégueulasse
il ya une liaison étroite entre
l'aléatoire et irréversible invité de ce
magazine d ar pieri car aviateurs
artisans il vient de réaliser son
premier film thierry car mon jour
pourquoi un film sur les ulm donc quand
je filme car vous êtes attaché un
passionné des ulm
ça ne date pas d'hier cette élection
écoutez le mieux je crois c'est
peut-être qu'on va en images ce que vous
avez réalisé un petit extrait tout de
suite du film de pierre ricard peuple
juge journée que qq qui se sont déroulés
course quatre beaux films américains le
groupe comprend tout à fait conseil est
tout le monde tout le monde
je vous remercie de votre attention
à demain la semaine prochaine les amours
célèbres ou la véritable histoire
d'amour du lys et de penelo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui unissent rentrant de son long
périple n'avait dans ses oreilles que le
chant des sirènes
si votre femme vous emmerde
faites comme moi fait le coup des
sirènes c'est facile et ça marche à tous
les coups
[Musique]
on sait d'humoristes qui n'ont vraiment
vous n'avez rien monsieur codou déjà aux
yeux des formules être chaud oui nom
prénom âge et dernier emploi alors fait
chaud violette chocolat 22 ans
mettez 22 ans ahmed dernières emploient
péripatéticienne en trois mots
péripatéticienne dans votre secteur
alors là il n'y a plus rien le marché
complètement saturé n'ont rien du tout
vous étiez vous j'ai fait sur les grands
boulevards j'avais une très très bonne
petite clientèle fumeuse et très bon
mois non j'ai rien du tout ça fait comme
en tant que vous avez arrêté de
travailler
ça fait un petit mois quoi au juste il
avait dû perdre la main a pas du tout à
ça j'ai pas perdu la main monsieur pulga
entre nous j'ai travaillé au noir géant
dont le corps n'a pas de racines mission
nadine pe
tout le monde a droit au travail gervais
1 rue
non tout est bloqué là c'est peut-être
un truc la rue car banal dans le
quartier des fonctionnaires à la carte
ya les fonctionnaires quelle horreur
monsieur j'ai commencé aux cartes et les
fonctionnaires j'estime qu'à l'heure
actuelle je tue devenue une
professionnelle une méritante et je
tiens évoluer dans mon travail c'est pas
la peine de regarder j'ai rien n'y
faisait je suis désolé en prénationale
et moi je vous en prie faites un petit
espoir et des mois oui ce mail voyage
oui je suis prête à déménager s'il le
faut je peux peut-être vous aider j'ai
mon frère mon frère a déjà fait pas mal
de choses pour certaines de vos
collègues s'ils sont évidemment
moyennant commission je suis prête à
tout va prosper est dans les parages on
espère bien voir ici c'est la nouvelle
pour tanger
moi pour avoir de beaux cheveux
j'utilise mejor major et un shampoing
100% naturel fait à base de guano
d'excréments de poule
mais je dors à shampoing 100% naturel la
dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine amouk et le prince lui
victime des sortilèges de merlin le
chanteur cherche une solution pour
retrouver leur apparence normale je peux
pas rester comme ça bouge pas on va
aller voir et fait des fautes et je
crois que c'est fermé le mardi
c'était bien on va quand même essayer
samedi ma mère est là rien n'a rien
mesdemoiselles
nous allons aujourd'hui aborder la leçon
27 chapitres 49/100 les doigts de ton et
maman sur leur propre je compte sur
votre vigilance
le syndicat a toujours raison le sluc a
toujours raison qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous savez pas lire
c'est fermé le mardi il faut toujours
obéir aux syndicats il faut toujours
d'accord vous nous écoutez milou crottes
il ne faut pas oublier de payer ses
cotisations au syndicat ni pourquoi
payer ses cotisations syndicales
paulino reset ces thèmes où vous me
reprenait tout ça plus fort s'il vous
plaît il ne faut pas pauline il ne faut
pas payer ses cotisations au syndicat du
silence on veut retrouver notre
apparence à vous voulez transformer au
oui oui transformer nous allez les
filles le sens vannes chaque chapitre 42
m'étonnerait pas qu'elle l'ait fait
exprès je les connais
[Musique]
ah ah
monsieur charles tricot l'eau un des
chefs de l'opposition nationale n'y va
pas de main morte
lors du dernier congrès de son parti
il accuse notre corporation de
complaisance voire de complicité totale
vis-à-vis du pouvoir en place
eh bien monsieur charles tricot l'eau
puisque vous accuser directement notre
rédaction
je vais vous répondre au nom de tous mes
confrères nous nous les journalistes de
gauche
nous savons ce qu'est l'objectivité nous
savons ce qu'est l'indépendance d'esprit
indépendance objectivité de vous ignorer
complètement vous hein vous la droite a
pointé par le comité des forges et les
nervis de la cia mort mon renard vie
fasciste non au grand capital
vive l'indépendance d'esprit vive la
liberté de la presse
vive la gauche unie vive monsieur le
ministre de l'information
nous avons le pouvoir et nous garderons
[Musique]
non
là
- co j toulouse le savons parce que le
savon au menu je trouve que mon macbook
est aussi ça fait dix ans ça fait dix
ans que je travaille à l'usiné de savon
mon minou mais je peux vous assurer et
collez les savons mon minou sont
vraiment des savons pur chat c'est
vraiment en plus il est 100% pur cher
[Musique]
du siala c'est à la portée de tous
tout dépend évidemment de la direction
d'acteurs par exemple le dialogue entre
ces deux personnages as-tu pensé à
acheter le pain oui mais j'ai oublié de
prendre le sel c'est tout chéri que la
charcuterie d'à côté fermé non c'est
dommage le boudin il était très bon on
peut prendre des formes diverses selon
le metteur en scène à la manière de cluj
[Musique]
oui je vais prendre le set en fait c'est
du shérif que la charcuterie d'à côté
fermé c'est dommage
le baudrier bon
[Musique]
federico fait penser à acheter le pain
mais je pense acheter le pain mais j'ai
complètement oublié de prendre celle du
shérif de la charcuterie d'actualité
pour le canada 1 ap 4
le projet autour des mots la manière de
jean luc godard dû penser à prendre le
bain oui mais j'ai oublié de prendre le
cerf au fait tu sais tu que la
charcuterie d'à côté fermé c'est dommage
ne voudrait tellement samedi
achetez nouba oui
j'ai oublié de prendre le sel
[Musique]
oui
en fait la charcuterie d'à côté fermé
[Musique]
le good eye atp
as-tu pensé l'attend dans le principe
mais j'ai oublié de prendre le sel aux
petits chéris que la charcuterie des
territoriaux est très dommage
le boudin était si beau
[Musique]
m
j'ai pensé à prendre comme je vais
prendre le sac tu te caches astrid a
coûté cher mais personnellement j'ai
cette version là qu'on préfère
[Musique]